I've come together with the one on my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter bone sisters helped to feed those
who are in poor conditions and who don't
even have a clothing to keep theirself
warm your small donation might mean
nothing to you but it can change their
life and help them survive the winter
this year hey bro this is the UK bug
who's this man in my ends cause are you
mad but we do about what are you doing
in my mind don't be touching my jackets
I'm Mexican too bro
listen listen listen let me make up to
you bro you like Persian food
why what's up with that let me let me
treat you bro this is the UK you are
your guest bro come on
I'm gonna get you a nice land kebab and
some aubergine he doesn't look like a
Muslim but what does a Muslim look like
and is there a specific type of Muslim
uh
say one thing Philip I did this
interview because
this I feel like this is a positive for
me to get stronger in what I do in real
life because I you know I'm from the
streets I realize life and what you're
doing for the people in the community is
solid and this has given me inspiration
to be a better person by doing your
interview you know what you gave me
inspiration to go
but you inspired me more